- I don't know a lot of lotion people,
but I know they do a lot of this.
(light scratchy noise)
(light clapping)
(uptempo beat)
- Bath & Body Works is a store
that I never want to go in at the mall,
but I always get dragged
to it by my girlfriend.
- Early 2000s, all my girlfriends were 12,
but we were all like, "Let's go!"
- I think they have a lot of soap.
I think that they have a lot of baskets
that have soap in it.
(upbeat jazz music)
(sniffing sound)
- This feels like something that
a 12 year old girl would wear.
- Like I'm walking through the woods
in Medieval England and
I'm picking a cherry
and I smell it.
- I would call this
Watermelon Body Butter.
- Dainty Moonberry Sunrise.
(upbeat jazz music)
(gasps and chokes)
- Okay, that was a bad idea.
- This should be called
Holy Crap, Don't Spray
This Anywhere Near Children
'Cause They Will Light On Fire.
- Laundry's Done! That's
what this should be called.
It does smell very fresh. I'd wear it.
(upbeat jazz music)
- Oh, this smells like hairspray.
You can call this Aqua Net.
- Old Lady's House by Bed Bath & Beyond.
- Plumeria? That's awful.
- Oh! Happy Birthday, honey.
I got you Plumeria.
What, you got me a disease?
No, it's this awesome fragrance
from Bath & Body Works!
(upbeat jazz music)
- Looks like I'm about to
put some mayo on my skin.
- This is like I'm in Paris, France
hanging out with Kanye West.
- This has gotta be lemon hand lotion.
- This is why I don't use lotion
'cause my hands feel creepy right now.
(upbeat jazz music)
- (sniffing noise) Oooh.
- I hate to be talking
about poop right now,
it's not my style, but
that's how bad this smells.
- I would buy this for
my girlfriend, for sure.
- I like this one, but this again just
smells like a very juvenile smell.
- At Bed Bath & Beyond, they just do
whatever the hell they want.
They make up smells.
- Err. What did I say?
(upbeat jazz music)
- Hello, old friend! I would
recognize her anywhere!
(light clapping)
(sniffing noise)
- Man, I wanna eat this one.
This one smells like candy.
- I feel this one would be the
Britney Spears of the lotion.
- I can't stop smelling my hands.
They just smell great.
- Bath & Body Works, thank
you for everything you've done
in the past 20 years.
You've helped a lot of
stinky teens make it through.
- In the 90s, I was a little kid.
I was smelling Play Doh,
N64 cartridges, Gak.
- Bath & Body has some good stuff there.
Probably still won't go,
but I appreciate them
for what they are.
- I didn't tell my girlfriend
I was going to be in this.
I'm wondering what she's going
to think when I get home,
(laughs) if I come home
smelling like a 90s girl.